اكدت المتحدثه باسم مجلس الامن القومي ان
الولايات المتحده ابحاث عن اساليب لمواجهه
انتاج ايران للمسيرات وذلك من خلال
العقوبات ومنع التصدير والتحدث الى
الشركات التي تستعمل ايران قطاعها في
الانتاج هذا التصريح يدل اولا على ان
الولايات المتحده وحلفائها لن يتمكلوا من
فرض حصار بالقوه يمنع ايران من مساعده
روسيا في حرب اوكرانيا
لم تمنع استمرار ايران في انتاج المسير
سيارات الكثير من هذه التكنولوجيا والقطاع
استعمالها مزدوج ومن المستحيل منع ايران
من الحصول عليها
التحدي الاكبر الذي تواجه الولايات
المتحده هو ان صناعه المسيرات الايرانيه
تستعمل قطعا متوفره في الاسواق العالميه
لوضعها على محركات المسيره وغالبيه القطاع
من اشباه الموصلات والمحركات الصغيره
متوفره للهواه وتمكن الايرانيون من ديلها
الى اسلحه
من المستحيل تقريبا منع موده تجاريه من
الوصول الى يد الطرف الذي لا ترغب به
المره الاولى التي تم فيها الحديث عن هذه
المشكله كان في تقرير لمؤسسه امريكيه
بدايه الخريف الماضي وقالت ان القطاع
تستوردها ايران من النمسا والمانيا
وبريطانيا والولايات المتحده
من الاستيراد من الاسواق الغربيه لكن
التحدي الاكبر يعود الى اسواق الصين ربما
لا تستطيع الولايات المتحده ايران من
تصنيع المسيارات والصواريخ وسيكون على
واشنطن وحلفائها تعزيز المساعدات العسكريه
لاوكرانيا خصوصا المضادات الجويه وهي تفعل
الكثير من ذلك
ولم تستعمله لاسقاط مسيرته يبلغ ثمنها
اربعه الاف دولار اوكرانيا تحتاج الى
اعتاد للدفاع عن بنيتها التحتيه والمدنيين
خصوصا الاسلحه قصيره المدى والاقل تماما
هناك اساليب كثيره في لعبه الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه لمساعدته اوكرانيا لكن
المشكله لدى واشنطن هو ان ايران اخذت جانب
روسيا وسيكون من المستحيل على طهران ان
تغير موقفه في الغنم العربيه واشنطن